Film Courage: How many film submissions
did you watch total from your running
NFFTY [National Film Festival for Talented Youth]?
Jesse Harris, Filmmaker: I think I probably
watched nearly 10,000 films, a lot. We were
getting thousands of submissions. In the first
few years I was watching every single one of them.
Eventually we got more people involved to do
pre-screening and start I don't want to say
eliminating but limiting films but we were
always very fair. We had multiple people watch
every film so it wasn't just one person deciding
on it. But yeah I watched a ton of films while
doing the festival. I think it definitely had
an impact on me because for one I saw a lot of
really bad films of course and so I saw what
not to do and how to learn from that. Then I
saw every once in a while so I saw some incredible
movies that were just like mind blown! I was like
how did someone my age make this and so it was
it was probably again this like amazing almost
film school like experience but in an even more
probably modern way of just watching all these
films from all over the world of all different
kinds raw and super professional and getting on
one hand analyzing them as a viewer and being
like would people like this and should this be
in the festival but also as a filmmaker being like
wow look what they did or whew, look what they did
and how we should not do that and so it probably
I'm sure contributed a lot in terms of expanding
my filmmaking knowledge college and abilities
after watching so many films for so many years.
Film Courage: Then what do you think
makes a bad movie? What were some of
the things where you could almost tell
within the first maybe 30 seconds?
Jesse: I think it was just not telling
an authentic story, someone trying to
copy something that they had seen already like
making action spoof on some movie they liked
or doing something probably the mistakes we all
do which is like trying to copy something and not
having any original I deal with it and I think
to just sometimes trying to do maybe too much
because we had plenty of films that were very
simple made with no money and sometimes those
were some of the best films but then
you had someone who was maybe trying
to do two something too ambitious for
what they the resources they had maybe
there was always issues with acting of course
performances because you're probably limited on
who you can get there was technical challenges
but I honestly don't think a test the technical
ability of a film is always really the
best judge of it you could have a really
raw film that doesn't have the most amazing
cinematography or whatever but if it has a really
great story it can be super successful so I think
it was always just trying to find those stories
that that were captivating and whether that was
a documentary or a short film or whatever but
yeah it was just trying to find those just really
captivating stories from your time with NFFTY what
did you see with the submissions that you found
really made a film satisfying any genre I think
what makes the film satisfying is when it makes
you feel something and whatever that is whether
it's a sad feeling a happy feeling being scared
whatever I think that that was when I knew we had
a good film was what I was after watching hundreds
if not thousands of films you get a little numb
sometimes but then you turn one on while screening
them for the festival and it would just Captivate
you and grab your attention and make you feel
something and if it can make you feel something
after watching tons of other films and being
bored and over over that then it's probably gonna
Captivate everyone else and so that's what I was
always looking for was what are those just really
compelling films that would make me feel something
whatever that was and I think that's the same with
anything now and that's what I try to think
about when I make a film too is just how can I
make people feel something and I think for for me
that was always trying to tap into emotion because
that's just what I always went to for some people
it might be comedy or something else but I think
if you can if you can do that you can you can make
a great film what about a non-nifty submission
what was one that made you feel something however
old you were as a kid my parents actually would
either take me to a lot of movies or we had a
video store near our house and so we would rent a
lot of films and it was like an independent video
store so it was we'd sometimes find movies that
would wouldn't be a blockbuster or something like
that and so I actually probably had a pretty good
Movie experience as a kid watching probably
a lot of movies that were more older than I
really was like not necessarily kid movies but
like I remember being pretty young and watching
To Kill a Mockingbird and I remember at first
my mom had rented it and she said you have to
watch this and we did but it was like it was in
black and white and for the first few minutes I
was like this is going to be boring like what is
this like I was very young at the at the time but
then within probably the first five minutes I was
totally hooked because it is such a captivating
story right has great characters and also there
was these young kids in the movie which I was
probably the same ages as them on the screen and
so I think that hooked me and so I think it's the
it's the same idea where if a movie can grab you
and grab at your emotions or or Captivate you in
some way it's gonna have you and then obviously
from there you still have to have the rest of the
film be compelling good acting good storytelling
otherwise but I think that's just so important
is just to have something what's something
that's going to grab people and pull you in
any success stories with NFFTY that really stand
out like whether it was a film that just drew you
in or maybe a filmmaker that you were so compelled
by their story their real story definitely I think
I saw so many amazing films over the many years I
was running the festival one in particular was it
was this young female filmmaker from Afghanistan
and she had pulled off making this film
and it was a documentary about her life and
this was in I don't know late 2010s I guess
I don't know obviously this was like wars were
going on all over in that area and it was just so
profound I guess to see this story from someone
your own age from around the world and then she
actually came out to the festival and we got to
meet her which was incredible and there was there
were so many other interesting stories like that
there was I think especially the documentaries at
our Festival were so compelling just because they
were so personal and real and raw and so we had
amazing short narrative films also all the time
but the documentaries were just so special because
they were coming from basically someone your own
age telling some usually some really profound
amazing story from their life and so those were
always just so compelling and captivating and we
were able to find films from really all over the
world and all walks of life and it was it was just
always exciting really every time we would get
a submission in and see what this story was and
a lot of our filmmakers have gone on to to do big
things they've a couple of them made feature films
one we had a short documentary in the festival
several years back that won the Oscar for best
short documentary that year so it's it's been this
great I guess you could just call it like a farm
team or whatever I guess for for finding these
filmmakers and helping them develop themselves
but of course not every filmmaker goes on and
has a big success story most of the filmmakers
if you touched with them now like they probably
won't even be still directing like the reality is
it's just obviously very hard and not everyone
that makes a film when they're in their early
20s ends up becoming a director but a lot of them
are working in the industry somewhere or they're
just doing something else in their life that is
creative and they're using their skills probably
as a filmmaker to to tell still tell stories in
some way whether it's marketing or whatever and so
I think that's the big thing is that no matter
what happens I think a lot of anyone who can
put together a film and go down that path it's
just such a great experience for for learning
about yourself but also about how to like tell a
story and Captivate people and I just think it's
a great skill in life that you can use one way
or the other did you see where filmmakers who
were overseas maybe did you realize I guess what
privilege we have here in terms of being able to
make something withstanding certain laws whereas
in other countries probably much much different
much more fear yeah for sure there was definitely
films at times we had a few of our filmmakers
especially from the Middle East who would get
into our Festival but then they wouldn't even
be able to travel necessarily to the US to attend
the festival sometimes that was because of their
own country other times it was because the U.S
wouldn't let them in and it was definitely a
time period too again it was like the internet
was was starting to take off more this was like
Facebook and social media was was existing but
it still was like the world wasn't as close and
connected as it is now and it was always so
captivating captivating when we would get to
meet these young filmmakers from around the world
and cure firsthand for them just their experiences
of their everyday life because it was and that
was what was so special about the festival is
you would literally have everyone from a very
privileged probably wealthy family to someone
who's poor and we had to basically raise money to
bring them out to the festival and we did that in
some cases and so so but we all were the same in
the end of the day because we're all filmmakers
just trying to tell stories and it was such a
special thing to see see everyone from all walks
of life interacting and and getting to share and
learn from each other and I think yeah more than
anything I think most young people will understand
this because it's in general they're more exposed
to people probably from around the world but I
think you start to it just makes you realize how
similar everyone is and how most of the conflicts
and problems would probably be solved if we were
all just like hanging out with each other
a lot more but making movies yeah exactly.